morning all and we begin with the
breaking news that novak djokovic will
not be defending his australian open
title a court in australia dismissed his
last-ditch appeal against the
cancellation of his visa the tennis
men's number one is now set to be
deported this guy's melinda veselninovic
is standing by in the newsroom at
morning melinda just take us through
that which we heard from the judge and
the reasons for it
sunil it was um a judgment that cannot
be appealed against it was made
unanimously by three judges which means
this is the end of the road for novak
djokovic in australia then world number
one has lost his bid to stay it's a
really disastrous end for the ten rather
chaotic days that he's spent in
australia we've actually just heard from
the world number one who's released a
short statement i'm going to read you a
little bit of that statement he says
i'm extremely disappointed with a court
ruling to dismiss my application for
judicial review of the minister's
decision to cancel my visa which means i
cannot stay in australia and participate
in the australian open i respect the
court's ruling and i will cooperate with
the relevant authorities in relation to
my departure from the country i'm
uncomfortable that the focus of the past
weeks has been on me and i hope that we
can all now focus on the game and
tournament that i love he also thanked
his supporters across the world saying
that they had been a source of strength
for him i had been in touch with his
father and his family throughout this
legal drama at this point they don't
feel like they can add much more to that
but this decision will certainly
reverberate in his home country
of serbia where the president had in
fact on friday accused the australian
prime minister scott morrison of using
novak djokovic to gain his political
point but
novak will be deported we presume to
serbia he's facing a three-year ban to
enter australia although that could be
reversed due to compelling circumstances
so that some wiggle room there still at
one point that the chief justice allsup
who
gave the decision on behalf of the three
judges there was one point that he
wanted to make clear that what he was
doing what the judges were doing were
not really deliberating on the merit of
the government's decision to quash the
visa what they were doing is deciding if
that decision had been taken
legally and i appreciate that's quite a
niche kind of nuanced
illegal view but basically having spoken
to legal experts ahead of this hearing
they were saying
barring the government making a
procedural mistake it would be very very
difficult for novak djokovic to be
successful in his bid and what's also
different this time round is that
the government took a much broader view
first time around when they uh there was
an appeal against the government's
decision to quash his visa it was based
on facts basically whether his
medical examination was valid now this
time around they said that he would
stoke anti-vac sentiments in the country
and that's much harder to basically
argue against
milina thanks very much indeed
uh we have just been hearing uh from
australia's immigration minister alex
hawk of course the person
that made the decision to rescind that
visa he has been commenting um and as
you might imagine he has welcomed the
unanimous decision by the federal court
of australia to uphold my decision to
cancel novak djokovic's visa more on
that when we get it about the
immigration minister but let's just
remind you as to the events that led up
to this hearing
novak djokovic's struggle with
australian authorities has now been
running for more than 10 days
he touched down in melbourne at half
past 11 on the 5th of january and was
then questioned by officials about his
vaccination exemption
after being held for about eight hours
he was denied entry his visa was
cancelled and he was sent to an
immigration hotel which he remained for
four nights
on the 10th of january in a virtual
court hearing uh djokovic's visa was
reinstated
he was released from detention
but the next day social media posts
emerged which seemed to contradict the
declaration he made on his immigration
form stating he did not travel for 14
days before entering australia and so
djokovic posted a statement apologising
for the mistake and blaming his agent
for taking the wrong box on a form
it was then announced he would be
included in the australian open draw but
as mentioned the next day immigration
minister alex hawk canceled the visa for
a second time and djokovic returned to
the immigration detention hotel where he
was previously held
all of this led up to today's
unsuccessful
attempt to overturn the visas rescinding
in the federal court of australia
as you can see our sports presenter
jackie beltran is back once again and we
have been hearing from djokovic he says
he's now going to be taking some time to
rest and recuperate before making any
further comments beyond the fairly
anodyne statement but he must be livid
um livid disappointed gutted you know he
is desperate to be remembered as the
greatest tennis player of all time one
more grand slam title and that is
absolutely not in question because he
will have the most grand slam titles of
the big three nadal and federer at the
moment they're all tied so that was his
opportunity as far as he saw it this
year
to go ahead and now that is gone he's a
nine-time champion in australia he loves
playing there
don't think he's done himself any favors
with the australian public he is the
player that really wants to be loved and
people were beginning to love him i
think this has probably set that cause
back quite a bit um we haven't heard
from any players as yet except for one
french player elise corney
has come out and spoken about the
judgment she said um i know that novak
is always the first one to stand up for
the players but none of us stood for him
be strong uh joe canole which is his um
twitter handle and the players have not
been that sympathetic to his cause uh
nadal said nobody
is um
above the law nobody should be given
special treatment and nobody is better
than the tournament and the tournament
is going to be good whether he's in it
or not you know schizophrenic he's made
us look like fools we're all vaccinated
why is he treading his own path so the
players have not really really feel like
he's been given special treatment by the
tournament organizers who wanted him to
play and have been and have been the
rules djokovic after all i mean he is
arguably the greatest player the game
has ever seen or at least one of two
yeah no absolutely and some people will
say he is the greatest player you know
that the game has ever seen and you know
you can see why craig tyley the
tournament director wanted him to be in
it but there is a feeling that you know
the rules weren't followed correctly and
had they just said if you want to come
to australia to play the australian open
you must be double vaccinated if you
don't want to be double vaccinated
that's your choice but you can't play
interestingly um what is going to happen
to novak now is he going to get
vaccinated is he going to face the same
problem at the french open potentially
he could you know future tournaments
down the line other tournaments in
australia will he be allowed to go to
australia for the next three years
because they could essentially say he
can't go there for another three years
um there are so many questions and he
has now got to go home and really
rethink his whole strategy you know this
whole holistic approach you know it is
commendable on on one hand but on the
other hand it's stopping him what he
what he does
which is which is play tennis and win
grand slam tournaments and he has not
won much sympathy amongst his his peers
on the tour
not the last time we will be talking
about the story i'm sure but for now
jackie thanks very much indeed